Wir sind hier, in der Auto. Alter, wir warten schon immer. Komm schon, wir müssen die Frage in Stonehaven beenden.
Was?
Du solltest nicht mit deinen Freunden zusammen socialisieren.
Ich bin mit einem MMORPG mit Leuten aus der ganzen Welt und bekomme XP mit meiner Party mit Teamspeak.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 73. 73 Chaosradio Express-Folgen und die letzten waren extrem technikgeschwängert, ging viel um Programmierung von allen möglichen technischen Systeme, Einblicke in Computersysteme, User-Interfaces, ach und was nicht alles und das war auch alles mal ganz nötig und sinnvoll, hat sich auch zwangsläufig ergeben, weil ich so ein bisschen auf Reisen war, aber jetzt bin ich wieder zurück in Berlin und ich nehme jetzt so die Themen auf, die schon ein bisschen länger geplant waren und auf der Liste standen und wo man dann endlich mal einen schönen Tag gefunden hat, wo man auch drüber reden kann und das Thema heute soll sein World of Warcraft, Multiplayer-Online-Spiele, ja weniger im Im Allgemeinen als vielmehr im Besonderen soll es im World of Warcraft gehen. Und ja, als kompetenten Ansprechpartner hab ich den Denis mit dabei. Hallo Denis. Dann muss ich mich jetzt erstmal entschuldigen bei dir, weil ich deine Aufnahme verkackt habe vom Chaosradio Express 57, wo es im BitTorrent ging. Da war noch der Erdgeist dabei und der Krügs, wo wir uns sehr ausführlich über BitTorrent unterhalten haben und auch über das Open-Tracker-Projekt über dem arbeitet. Und jeder, der das hier hört, dem kann ich auch noch mal empfehlen, in diesen Podcast reinzuhören, falls er den übersehen hat, weil er ist dann so ein bisschen unglücklich gelaufen. Ich hatte deine Spur irgendwie nicht aufgenommen, war halt so ein Multitrack-Recording. Ich habe zwar vier Spuren aufgenommen, aber eine doppelt und eben eine nicht. Na ja, dann habe ich irgendwie nach so einem Tool gesucht. Mit diesem Level-Later ging das dann so halbwegs, dass man eben so über das Signal, was die anderen Mikrofone noch mit aufgenommen haben, das noch so halbwegs drin hatte. Aber das war natürlich suboptimal. Aber heute ist ja alles ganz anders.
Also hat sich keiner so wirklich beschwert. Man konnte es wohl schwerer verstehen, aber man konnte es verstehen.
Man konnte es verstehen. Das war vielleicht jetzt nicht mehr so Straßenbahn-kompatibel, wie wenn jetzt richtig da ein knalliges Signal ist. Aber inhaltlich hatte zumindest keiner was auszusetzen, soweit ich das bemerkt habe. Ja, und ihr habt ja dann auch später noch einen Vortrag dazu gehalten auf dem Kongress. Wie war so da der Rücklauf?
Da kam einer, also die meisten sagten, es ist einer der coolsten Vorträge auf dem Kongress gewesen, was mir doch sehr gewundert hat. Ich dachte, das wäre so ein ganz normaler Tra-La-La-Vortrag, so ein bisschen Technik, ein bisschen so irgendwie.
Weil er da saß wie so die Cowboys auf der Veranda.
Ein bisschen so aus der, wie sagt man, Kiste erzählen hier. Wie sagt man, ist egal.
Aus einem Nähkästchen.
Aus einem Nähkästchen, genau. Ein bisschen in den Reihen so. Ja, aber die Leute fanden es eine schicke Mischung, nicht zu technisch, nicht zu langweilig. Also muss ich auch Spaß machen.
Ja, ich habe ihn so zu dreiviertel auch gehört und kann das nur bestätigen, war auf jeden Fall nett. Also war auch, sagen wir mal, sehr Podcaster. Hat vielleicht auch genutzt, dass wir hier schon mal irgendwie vorher saßen und so drüber geredet haben. Dann habe ich das eigentlich genauso gemacht. So mag ich die Sendung eigentlich auch immer am liebsten, auch bei Chaosradio. Also umso Wohnzimmergesprächmäßiger. Das ist so besser.
Ja, nur auf unsere Stichpunkte, diese abgearbeitet, dann muss man ja selbst noch mal nachdenken, was man erzählt, wenn man jetzt nicht so komplett fertig hat schon und vom so Text abliest, machen ja auch viele das nicht so spannend.
Jaja, Outlines runterbeten, das ist das Schlimmste, was man machen kann. Okay, ich nur vor Warn. Das machen wir nicht. Machen wir auch hier nicht. Wir haben jetzt hier nur so ein paar kleine Notizen gemacht, worüber, was wir so grundsätzlich anreißen wollen. Aber das ist hier alles nicht outline orientiert, sondern ja, das Phänomen ist interessant. Und ja, das Phänomen, über das wir jetzt reden wollen, ist World of Warcraft, ein Online, also ein sogenanntes MMORPG, also ein Massively-Multiplayer-Online-Roll-Playing-Game. Genau, das heißt, Rollenspiel kennen wir ja früher vielleicht auch, was weiß ich, hast du mal sowas gespielt irgendwie?
Na, in der TU gab es früher so ein Multiuserdungeon, das war alles textbasiert.
Das Original-MAT.
Genau, TU Berlin-MAT war ich. Und da habe ich auch eine Runde gezockt, da musste man auch wizard werden oder so. War es in Englisch, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, es könnte sein. Ich glaube schon, weil da war auch eine Amerikanerin.
Am Ende muss man immer wizard werden.
Man muss wizard werden.
Ja, dann kommt man nicht drüber.
Aber mehr weiß ich auch nicht, war schon, ist 15 Jahre hier. Jetzt klingelt hier irgendwas, aber das hört doch wieder auf.
Ach so, ist das das Telefon?
Meins wahrscheinlich.
Echt, deins? Ist doch okay. Ja, lass mich nicht aufhalten. Mat hast du gespielt.
Mat habe ich gespielt, genau. Und das habe ich mit einem Freund gespielt, dem Valti, sag ich jetzt mal, kennst du ja auch, ne?
Kenn ich.
Christoph. Genau. Und wir haben uns damals ein bisschen gezockt und dachten uns, ist ja alles schon ganz schick, aber irgendwann in der Zukunft, weil damals gab es ja auch schon hier so Wolfenstein, dieses ganz erste 3D-Schuh.
Krass, Wolfenstein.
Genau. Und diesen Multiuserdungeon, diesen textbasierten, den wollen wir eigentlich in der Zukunft irgendwann mal in 3D haben, wo man da so rumlaufen kann, wo alles was als Text ist, was man irgendwie sehen kann. Und es hat halt Jahre gedauert und irgendwie Anfang 2005 kam Christoph auf mich zu und meinte, hier World of Warcraft, jetzt ist es da. Er hatte schon irgendwie so ein Figürchen, einen Account, er hat sich das gekauft und meinte, hier, Denis, guck dir das mal an und spiel da auch mal.
Aber hast du vorher auch schon mal Rollenspiel gemacht, ohne Computer?
Nee, um Gottes Willen.
Nee, ich hab das mal gemacht.
Ich finde, bekloppt.
Das ist vielleicht auch bekloppt, das hat trotzdem Spaß gemacht. Dungeons & Dragons, das war ja sehr populär weltweit und in Deutschland das Schwarze Auge hier vom KNAUER-Verlag, die sind da so ein bisschen... Ich hab das mal gemacht. Ja, das war eigentlich sehr amüsant.
Ich kenne das gar nicht.
Das ist hochsozial. Also ich meine, auch den Aspekt werden wir noch mal beleuchten, aber das kann ich an der Stelle auch bestätigen. Also Rollenspiele spielen am Tisch, heißt ja, man muss sich da auch mal richtig ein bisschen am Riemen reißen und nicht nur jetzt irgendwie würfeln und irgendwelche kleinen Plastikfiguren auf Felder stellen, sondern man muss sich so eine Welt ausdenken. Also gerade, wenn man so der Meister ist, dann muss man sich halt erstmal eine Welt ausdenken, in der das alles stattfindet, mit irgendwie Wegen, die man bestreiten kann und Aufgaben, die man herausfinden kann. Das heißt, man investiert da schon mal sehr viel Zeit und dann sitzt man halt da und die anderen müssen halt dann sich in irgendwelche Charaktere reinwürfeln, so sich ihre Lebensenergien, sondern ihre Eigenschaften, was weiß ich, wie schnell, wie stark und so weiter sie sind, da ermitteln. Und mit diesen Charakteren düsen sie dann los und man sitzt dann eben so ein bisschen der, naja, man heute würde sagen, man ist dann der Computer und sagt, was halt passiert. So und also mir hat das total Spaß gemacht. Also irgendwann hat es mich dann natürlich auch langweilt, aber ein paar Freunde von mir sind auch sehr lange dabei geblieben.
Ich habe immer gehört von Freunden, die es machen und ich habe mir selber das immer total unspannend vorgestellt.
Ich fand das total spannend, weil es ja auch total spannend, man ist ja so ein bisschen wie Rätsel, also man muss ja so ein Rätsel lösen, so was halt sich jemand ausgedacht hat. Und dann kann man auch mal lustig machen, was weiß ich, ihr steht in einer Höhle und irgendwie die Wand ist zugemauert. Und dann versucht ich halt irgendwie ganz klug zu sein und bin irgendwie, ja ich klett da hoch und ziehe einen Ziegel aus der Wand und dann halt die Reaktion von dem Meister, der Ziegel fällt dir auf den Kopf, du verlierst irgendwie einen Lebensenergie-Punkt. Und man kann ja sehr pfiffig sein und vor allem muss ich aber auch auf Regeln einigen, und zwar auf Regeln einigen, die jetzt über das Regelwerk dieses Rahmenspiels hinausgehen, nämlich so dieses, ja wie sehr darf man halt jetzt übertreiben, wie fies darf man sein zueinander, inwiefern spielt man da wirklich King aneinander und miteinander. Und schnell sind wir dann auch zu übergegangen, auch das Regelwerk selber von diesem schwarzen Auge zu nehmen und dann zu verfeinern. Und dann haben wir dann irgendwie, was weiß ich, da saß ich dann in meinem C64 in Wieserwreit und hab dann tonnenweise Regelwerk gemacht. Wir hatten dann irgendwie so 20, 30 Seiten Regelwerk gemacht. Das war dann so kompliziert, dass uns keiner mehr verstanden hat. Wir haben diese Regel aber auch nie gemacht. Aber es hatte den interessanten Nebeneffekt, dass ich dabei super schreiben und Deutsch gelernt habe. Also danach hatte ich so Grammatik und Autografie hatte ich drauf.
Also ich habe viel gelernt mit Rollenspielen, an Grammatik oder an Leadership oder Management.
Kein Zweifel, dass da eine Menge zu lernen gibt. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall diese Fantasiewelten beflügeln die Leute, natürlich besonders die Jugend. Aber es ist bei Weim nicht nur ein auf Jugend reduziertes Phänomen.
Aber der Unterschied zwischen dem Schwarzen Auge und unserem World of Warcraft hier ist ja, dass beim Schwarzen Auge ist die Fantasie in deinem Kopf und das Bild und die Optik und die Idee halt genau. Aber ihr habt ja noch nicht mal den Text, also ihr müsst ja sozusagen eigentlich alles erfinden. Und bei World of Warcraft ist ja alles fertig. Da wird nichts selber...
Aber Gott sei Dank auch fertige Abenteuer irgendwie kaufen. Die kaufen, darauf basiert ja dieses Verkaufsprinzip, wobei die verdient dann immer ein bisschen albern. Also wir haben dann eher doch die eigenen gespielt.
Ja, aber das ist halt bei World of Warcraft eben gar nicht und deswegen ist es schon ein Stück weniger Rollenspiel vielleicht auch. Also ich habe zum Beispiel nie eine Rolle gespielt in VOV., sondern ich war immer ich selbst. Also ich könnte mich jetzt mal umschalten und könnte sagen, ich will jetzt richtig den fiesen, bösen Typ spielen, so ohne, so richtig euristisch und keine Rücksicht auf irgendwas könnte man ja in VOV machen, weil es ja ein Rollenspiel ist, aber das mache ich halt irgendwie nicht. Weiß ich auch nicht, liegt mir nicht so, meine Rolle zu wechseln.
Das heißt, du heißt ja auch Denis? Einfach Denis.
Voll bekloppt, ich weiß es. Ich heiße nicht Denis, weil Denis ging nicht und deswegen bei anderen Chats oder...
Denis2342?
Nee, DenisX.
Die besondere Note.
Man kann jetzt, wir greifen schon ein bisschen vor, aber es ist halt so, man kann jetzt in VOV auch seit ein paar Wochen oder Monaten seinen Namen ändern, kostet halt 4 Euro, für so einen Datenbankswechsel, aber man kann ihn ändern, sie gucken dann nochmal drüber, ob er politisch korrekt und traurig ist, die haben da schon hohe Auflagen, aber ich könnte mich umbenennen, wenn ich wollte. Hab ja schon drüber nachgedacht, aber gucken wir mal.
Du bist auch mehr so ein Real-Namen-Mensch, ne? Mir ist auch mal nicht gelungen, mir irgendwie ein Nickname zuzulegen.
Als ich jung war, wo andere Leute heute sich ihre Nicknames ausdenken, da gab's keinen Platz für lange Nicknames, da war irgendwie bei Donkey Kong Junior oder Jumpman Junior oder was auch immer alles, Loadrunner, da gab's drei Buchstaben, dann war Ruhr.
Tim hat da auch immer reingepasst, deswegen hatte ich auch keinen Bedarf.
Denis hat da nicht reingepasst, ich hab mich immer mit 3 Ds begnügt.
Damals hieß auch noch kein Mensch, Tim, jetzt ist das irgendwie seit 20 Jahren der populärste Vorname bei Kindern.
Ja, ist ja schrecklich.
Ja, ist furchtbar.
Gleich nach Kevin, oder?
Ich glaub vor Kevin, Tim ist die Eins.
Ist ja schrecklich. Na ja, vier Euro kann sich umbinden.
Okay, wir flüchten in World of Warcraft. Jetzt sollten wir vielleicht noch mal kurz erläutern, was es eigentlich ist. Du hast ja gesagt, Christoph hat irgendwie einen Account, das heißt, World of Warcraft ist ein Onlinespiel, wo man sich einen Account macht. Den muss man sich kaufen.
Man musste damals das Spiel irgendwie 40, 45 Euro musste man sich kaufen. Gibt es für PC, gibt es für Windows.
Und Mac meinst du?
Und man installiert sich das Spiel, das war damals auch schon relativ groß, 3, 4 Gigabyte, vielleicht auch schon 5. Weil die Welt ist doch ziemlich groß und die ganzen Grafikdaten, Texturen, das Terrain halt.
Das liegt alles auf dem Rechner? Das ist alles lokal?
Das liegt alles auf dem Rechner.
Das heißt, mit der Spielversion ist die Welt dann auch definiert?
Ja, da werden auch keine Texturdaten oder so nachgeladen. Das Einzige, was halt, weißt du, ein Onlinespiel, was zum Blizzard-Server geht, sind halt deine Bewegungen oder wenn dein Inventar sich ändert oder so, weil das verwalten die natürlich nicht.
Muss ja auch alles sehr schnell gehen. Aber es gibt auch da Software-Updates und...
Es gibt Software-Updates, die kommen automatisch. Man kann sich denen nicht verweigern. Also man muss die runterladen, sonst kann man nicht weiter spielen. Das ist nicht so wie beim OS, dass man sagt, dieses Update mache ich nicht, weil es mir zu unsicher ist. Man muss immer. Das macht er auch automatisch. Du sagst nur, ja, ja, dann lädt er runter. Interessanterweise kann man ja wieder erwähnen, auch Blizzard lädt per BitTorrent runter. Also da kommt so ein Download-Programm, das ist ein Programm, wo innerhalb drin ein Torrent-File liegt. Und sie haben dann so ein eigenes, geschriebenes BitTorrent-Client, der dann irgendwie den eigentlichen Inhalt runterlädt. Und ja, es funktioniert ganz super.
Weil da ist bestimmt auch ordentlich Nachfrage. Das sind auch ziemlich große Dateien, oder?
Das kommt drauf an, es gab auch schon mal, glaube ich, 800 Megabyte-Updates.
Das sind ja schon so Mac OS X-Update-Qualitäten.
Also es geht von ein paar Megabyte, wenn nur das Programm selbst geändert wird, wenn sie so einen Patch haben, weil irgendwas nicht richtig funktioniert, bis dass irgendwelche neuen Dungeons, Monster, sonst die Änderungen kommen, oder größere Geschichten.
Und dann kommen die Texturen und 3D-Daten.
Und dann kommen die Texturen, dann könnten es schon mal ein paar 100 MB werden. Ist dann aber halt nicht ganz so oft.
Das heißt, man braucht die Software, die installiert man sich. Man braucht also auch ein Betriebssystem, wo es läuft. Gibt es das eigentlich auch so für Linux oder so? Gibt es nicht? Gar nicht. Läuft nur auf Mac oder Windows. Und dann geht man irgendwie online. Und mit dem Kauf des Programms hat man dann auch den Account gekauft, oder wie?
Also man kriegt da so eine Art Key, der ist bei einem Programm dabei. Damit lockt man sich ein, damit ist man auch online auf der anderen Seite registriert. Weil Offline-Spielen geht gar nicht. Man kann nur online spielen.
Wie man für ein Online-Roll-Playing-Game ja vielleicht auch erwarten würde.
Und dann hat man auch, mit dem Kauf des Spiels kriegt man einen Monat frei. Weil das Spiel kostet pro Monat auch Geld. Und zwar in Deutschland 13 Euro. Wenn man gleich ein halbes Jahr nimmt, nur 11 Euro. Drei Monate 12 Euro. Pro Monat, versteht sich. Und in China z.B. glaube ich, zahlen man pro Stunde. Und nicht pro Monat. Ach.
Aber in China gibt es auch richtig viele User auch.
Ja, angeblich, wie wir vorhin gehört haben, die Hälfte der zurzeit 10 Millionen User sind irgendwie...
In China.
In China oder zumindest in Asien. Die Koreaner sind noch ganz verrückte Spieler. In Korea gibt es von der Regierung, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, eine Onlinespielbeschränkung, weil sie ihr Bruttosozialprodukt befürchten, dass es sinken könnte, weil zu viel gezockt wird.
Naja, am Ende haben sie bestimmt hochbegabte, gut ausgebildete Sozialwerker. Da werden wir nochmal drauf kommen. Aber jetzt wüsste ich ja ganz gerne nochmal so ein bisschen, wie man sich das vorstellen muss. Also jetzt zunächst nochmal mit diesem, man verbindet sich zum Server.
Ne, man startet das Spiel. Dann gibt es noch, man kann sich aussuchen, weil es gibt verschiedene, also es gibt verschiedene Welten. Es gibt nicht, also diese 10 Millionen User, oder sagen wir mal in Europa, ich weiß nicht, wie viele es sind, so 2-3 Millionen, die spielen ja nicht alle auf einem Server und die rennen nicht alle auf einer Welt rum. Sondern das wird auf, in Deutschland sind es vielleicht 100 oder 200 verschiedene Welten und eine muss man sich halt aussuchen. Man kann auch auf mehreren Welten eine Figur erstellen, einen Charakter.
Aber es sind jetzt nicht unterschiedliche Welten, sondern es ist immer die gleiche Welt, bloß mit einer anderen Population.
Genau, unterschiedliche Instanzen dieser Welt. Und da muss man sich halt eine aussuchen. Und dann gibt es aber schon auch noch so ein kleiner, also die Welt ist die gleiche, aber mit einem anderen Hintergrund. Und zwar gibt es PVP-Server und PVE-Server. Und zwar Player vs. Player und Player vs. Environment. Und dann gibt es halt Rollenspielserver. Auf den Rollenspielserver, die finden es halt doof, wenn man dort an einem anderen Spieler vorbeiläuft, der freundlich gesinnt ist und man ihn nicht gerüßt. Das sind die wirklichen Rollenspieler. Das sind die, die mit dem Schild durch den Wald rennen.
Wieso hast du ohne Schild durch den Wald? Echt?
Regenschirm reicht.
Und warum muss man bei den anderen mit dem Schild durch den Wald rennen?
Weil das sind halt, die spielen wirklich eine Rolle. Die gehen da drin auf, irgendwie die Dame zu grüßen und den anderen Krieger mit Respekt dem zu begegnen und seinen Feind zu respektieren oder wie auch immer. Und da läuft alles sitzsam zu politisch korrekt Mittelalter-Style.
Ach so, das sind dann die, die dann, wenn sie den Rechner ausmachen, dann zu ihrem Mittelalter-Festival.
Genau, der Unterschied ist, im Rollenspiel darfst du nicht übers Real-Life reden. Du darfst im Rollenspiel zwar schon fragen, wie spät ist, aber die sagen dir dann dort die Zeit. Na okay, ist die gleiche, ist ein bisschen blöd, ein blöder Vergleich. Aber im Rollenspiel-Server darfst du nicht sagen, ich muss jetzt zur Arbeit, ich muss jetzt raus. Sondern dann sagt man, ich bin müde, ich müsste mich jetzt mal niederlegen und dann geht man sich ausloggen oder so. Aber man darf nicht sagen, dass man jetzt zum Fließband arbeiten gehen muss.
Oder ich muss noch auf den Markt eine Ziege kaufen.
Na, nicht wenn du das im echten Leben machst. Außer im Spiel schon.
Du werfst ja halt irgendwas aus, oder was weiß ich.
Genau, als Ausrede.
Ja, und da Kirchturm wird eingeweiht.
Irgendwie so. Und das ist der Unterschied. Und in dem PVP-Server, das ist halt Player vs.
Player. Sind diese Server dann explizit so markiert, oder weiß man das?
Ja, die kann man sich aussuchen. Aha, so ein Oldschool. Also man sagt erstmal, welche Art man haben möchte. Ich bin auf so einem Player vs. Player-Server, da wo alles geht, wo richtig gegeneinander gemetzelt wird.
Von der Software sind die nicht anders. Sondern es gibt nur eine andere Konvention. Und so ein PVP-Server heißt, wir hauen uns einfach gegenseitig die Birne ein, weil früher haben wir unsere Jugend mit Techen verschwendet und wir können nichts anderes.
Environment.
Das heißt, man fällt Bäume.
Na, man löst halt die Dungeons und die Aufgaben, aber es geht nicht so, also es gibt ja zwei verschiedene Fraktionen bei World of Warcraft. Die Horde und die Allianz. Und die sind, wird von Blizzard auch so provoziert. Die haben halt, wie sagt man, Streitpunkte oder halt Reibpunkte.
Reitpunkte?
Reib.
Ach, Reibpunkte.
Also Konfliktpunkte, wo ein Streit entsteht halt. Also die Battlegrounds gibt es halt, um sich zu kloppen. Und dann gibt es auch bestimmte Stellen, wo halt die Horde hin muss, wo die Allianz auch hin muss und wo man sich gegenseitig bekriegen kann. Und das wird von Blizzard gefördert. Das ist bei PvP so.
Und wer ist die Horde und wer ist die Allianz?
Kann man sich auch suchen.
Ach so, man ist entweder oder. So blau gegen rot.
Genau.
Die Horde und die Allianz. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt so einsteige, dann muss ich mir erstmal darüber Gedanken machen, in was für einer Welt ich eigentlich leben will. Will ich irgendwie mit den Oldschoolies, die irgendwie die Realität raushalten und immer das Schild durch die Gegend tragen? Oder möchte ich jetzt irgendwie immer auf der Fresse kriegen? Ich darf austeilen. PvE ist dann sozusagen das Spiel so ein bisschen mehr, wie es gedacht war. Ich spiele das Spiel oder ist da gar nichts so gedacht?
Da ist halt nicht so viel los.
Ach so, wo ist denn am meisten los?
PvP, da gibt es auch die meisten Server von.
Okay, also mitten auf der Fresse ist am meisten populär. Okay, alles klar. Gut, dann gehen wir zu PvP, weil das am meisten los. Und wenn ich dann da bin, muss ich mich dann irgendwie beim Einloggen entscheiden, du bist Horde oder du bist Allianz?
Genau.
Das ist so der erste Button, oder was?
Das musst du machen, weil du entweder kannst oder entweder oder.
Wird einem da irgendwas, eine Argumentation, nagelegt, was einen jetzt dazu bewegen sollte, das eine oder das andere zu werden? Oder ist das eher so Würfel?
Die Horde war früher, die waren immer hässlich, weil Orks sind hässlich, Tauren sind hässlich und Untote sind hässlich. Die Allianz waren immer Menschen, Elfen, Zwerge und Gnome.
Ach so, die guten, die Weißen und die Schwarzen so ein bisschen.
So ein bisschen, ja. Deswegen kam mit der Erweiterung, auf die wir später noch zurückkommen, wurden auch auf der Horde die Blutelfen eingeführt, die ein bisschen schicker waren, damit man auch auf der Horde was Schickes spielen konnte. Und bei der Allianz wurden die Draenei eingeführt, die waren nicht schick. Also sozusagen wurde es ein bisschen umgedreht.
Okay, damit das nicht ganz so schwarz-weiß-mäßig ist.
Da kamen neue Rassen dazu.
Das heißt, dadurch, dass ich sage, ich bin Horde oder Allianz, dadurch wird dann auch schon vorgegeben, von welcher Rasse mein Avatar sein darf.
Genau, weil die Allianz hat natürlich andere Rassen als die Horde. Habe ich ja die schon gerade aufgezählt.
Ja, okay, so wusste ich auch noch nicht. Das heißt, dann sage ich mal, ich bin jetzt irgendwie die Horde. Was habe ich da so für Rassen zur Auswahl? Orks?
Orks, Tauren, Untote, Blutelfen und war noch irgendwas. Ich glaube, es war noch irgendwas, habe ich vergessen.
Okay, Tauren sind dann so Pferde oder was?
Nein, so eine Art Kühe.
Ach so, Zentauren, Kühe?
Ja, Ochsen oder so.
Ach so, ja Stier, klar, Tauros.
Genau, weißt du, was in Red Bull drin ist.
Na klar, Stier. Was ist das eigentlich drin? Stiersperma oder was?
Ja, was auch immer.
Na was auch immer. Wir haben das jetzt nicht gesagt. Auf jeden Fall, gut, das heißt, ich bin dann so ein Tauros und laufe dann so etwas gehörend durch die Gegend.
Halt, halt, da musst du ja erstmal noch aussuchen, jetzt hast du ja eine Rasse, da musst du dir ja noch aussuchen, welche Klasse du spielen willst.
Aha, was heißt das?
Das heißt, es gibt ja Magier, Hexenmeister, Druiden, Paladine, Krieger, Priester.
Das heißt, das ist sozusagen von der Rasse unabhängig, also egal, wie hässlich ich bin.
Eine bestimmte Rasse kann nur bestimmte Klassen spielen.
Das heißt, das wird dadurch auch festgelegt?
Genau.
Das heißt, als Untru, da kann man kein Magier werden?
Doch, Magier schon, aber zum Beispiel kein Krieger, glaube ich. Bin mir aber jetzt auch nicht ganz so sicher, aber ich spiele keine Horde und ich habe nur meine eine Figur.
Okay, du bist Allianz? Okay, dann sag doch mal, was du so bist.
Ich bin Allianzler, ich bin Mensch und Magier.
Okay, also du hast ja eher so ein klassisches Profil.
Ja, schön hinten stehen und im Ballern.
Okay, und du bist Magier. Und sind da nicht alle Magier und alle Menschen irgendwie? Man hat das Gefühl, man ist in so einer angepassten Welt, wo irgendwie alle nur Menschen und Magier sind?
Nee, das ist gar nicht so.
Gibt es da Statistiken darüber, wie so die Verteilung ist von Rassen und Klassen?
Ich glaube, bei Blizzard gibt es...
Wir trinken heute übrigens nicht Club-Mate, sondern Bionade. Und auch in Prenzlauer Berg trinken wir Bionade.
Ich bin Mitte. Club-Mitte.
Mitte Club-Mate.
Ich glaube, die Klassenverteilung ist schon relativ gleichmäßig. Jetzt merkt man, wenn man in so einer Gilde ist, dann gibt es von jeder Klasse immer etwas ausgewogen.
So, und jetzt...
Hast du dir eine Figur ausgesucht?
Genau, die Wolken reißen auf und dann plumpst sich dann irgendwo so ein Wald.
Da kommt so ein schickes, ich habe es erst vor einer Woche wieder erlebt, ich habe einen Freund angefangen, kommt so ein schickes Intro-Video, wird ein bisschen über die Welten erzählt. Und dann macht es plopp und dann stehst du in so einer friedlichen Wäldchen mit so einem kleinen Häuschen irgendwie oder einem Rathaus, was es ist, stehst du da und bist Level 1 und kannst nichts.
Und dann muss man sagen, look room.
Nee, man muss nichts mehr sagen. Du bist ja kein Text-Adventure und du hast deine Maus.
So kenne ich das noch.
Die Tastatur und dann kannst du da rumlaufen, rumspringen.
Hast du immer auch Zork gespielt seinerzeit eigentlich? Noch mal ein bisschen in die Vergangenheit.
Was, dieses Infocom-Adventure?
Genau, diese Infocom Text-Adventure.
Ich habe Trinity gespielt. Trinity?
Hast du das auch von Infocom? Ich habe nicht viel Zeit damit verbracht, aber ich habe mal das von Douglas Adams, das Hitchhiker's Guide. Den gibt es ja auch als Infocom-Adventure. Das hat Douglas Adams selber mitgestaltet. Und das ist so dermaßen großartig. Es fängt irgendwie an mit You see nothing. Und dann irgendwie fängst du an mit diesen Klassikern. Look room, you see nothing. Ja, go north, you can't see. Look here, look there. You see nothing, you see nothing. Du bist wahnsinnig. Verstehst du das so? Das allererste. Nein.
Sondern?
Open eyes. Das heißt, das muss man dann erstmal bringen. Und es ist halt alles extrem Douglas-esque. Also wer das mal ausspielen will, gibt es bestimmt, dass es gibt, ich weiß, dass diese Info kommen.
Die Engines gibt es, die alten Dateien gibt es natürlich auch.
Das müsste sich zu finden sein. Machen wir selber nochmal gucken, ob ich da im Netz einen guten Link finde. Dazu kann ich auf jeden Fall empfehlen. Aber ich schweife ab. Wir sind also jetzt bei World of Warcraft.
Bei Level 1 sind wir schon.
Wir sind schon bei Level 1. Das heißt, ich hänge jetzt von diesem Rad raus rum und irgendwie der Wind weht und es ist ja auch alles extrem impressive. Die 3D-Grafik von World of Warcraft ist nicht schlecht.
Ich würde behaupten, die 3D-Grafik technisch gesehen ist nicht allzu doll. Aber der Level-Design und die passende Musik dazu und das ganze Drumherum, die Optik, die Farbgestaltung des Horizonts und des Himmels und all das, das ist alles ziemlich super. Also ich bin beeindruckt jedes Mal wieder, wenn ich in eine neue Welt komme. Ich spiele immer ein bisschen im Club und ich muss immer Show zocken. Das heißt, ich spiele und dann sind irgendwie ein, zwei, drei Leute, die mir zugucken. Das sind auch, wo ich sage, das wären eigentlich prima Spieler, die mir helfen können. Weil Zusammenspielen macht ja am meisten Spaß. Die wollen natürlich alle nicht, weil sie wissen, dass das ihre Freizeit kostet. Aber zugucken können die auch genauso lang, wie ich spiele. Es macht unheimlich Spaß, nur zuzugucken. Und die sagen auch alle jedenfalls, dass das Level-Design und die Optik einfach ungeschlagen ist. Also hier, der Far Cry, hier Crisis, sieht bestimmt schicker aus, von dem 3D-Zeug und Bäume, die wehen und die man umschießen kann und die dann runterfallen und so. Das geht bei WoW alles nicht. Es ist schon relativ statisch, aber die Optik ist trotzdem erstaunlich.
Ansprechend.
Also da haben wirklich Leute Mühe gegeben, das merkt man richtig. Also da gibt es so einen Level, eine Karte, die ist so ein bisschen afrikanische Steppe so angehaucht. Und da ist auch halt der passende Wind dazu, wo man richtig hört, dass er durch die Gräser weht. Und das ist einfach, das passt alles. Oder in einer Wüste hast du so einen Zischen und Pfeifen und so ein, wie der Wind durch die Steine so durchpfeift, irgendwie das ist dann in einer Wüste.
Das heißt, man spielt das auch in der Regel mit Headset auf? Also mit Kopfhörer?
Also ich mache das jetzt gerade nicht so. Aber als ich in einer Gilde war, was ich zurzeit nicht bin, da gab es halt Teamspeak, kommen wir vielleicht später noch zu, und dann hast du sowieso Headset mit Mikro.
Aber jetzt hat man dann auch so räumliche Sounds? Also hört man so Dinge von links und rechts kommen und so?
Also wenn einer an dir vorbei reitet, dann reitet der von rechts oder von links irgendwie um dich rum.
So, aber was muss man denn jetzt da tun? Ich muss sagen, ich fühle mich bei 3D-Spielen immer so ein bisschen... Also ich habe da... Es ist eine dieser Sachen, wo ich sehr schwer Zugang finde. Ich habe da so umgelaufen.
So ging es mir auch mal. Ich habe mal Neverwinter Nights irgendwie ausprobiert. Ich weiß gar nicht genau, was es war, ob das man kaufen muss oder wie das funktioniert, aber ich habe es irgendwie mal gemacht und war da in so einem Raum und bin so rumgelaufen. Und dann wusste ich halt nicht, weil mir auch keiner irgendwas gesagt hat, was ich machen muss. Und dann habe ich es nach einer Viertelstunde wieder aufgegeben, weil ich fand es irgendwie voll doof. Da der Christoph aber natürlich schon irgendwie losgezockt hat, hatte ich schon ein bisschen einen, der mir ein bisschen sagt, was ich machen muss. Und ja, dann lernt man so die einfachsten Sachen, dass man sich erstmal zurechtfindet und in einer Karte irgendwie so ein paar Sachen und wie man das bedient und sein Charakterfenster sich anguckt und so weiter und so fort. Und dann levelt man halt los, erfüllt Aufgaben.
Wie ist denn das User-Interface? Also man hat da so Fullscreen eigentlich das Spiel, aber man hat dann so Overlays, wo man so Dinge sieht.
Man hat Overlays, wo man Dinge sieht und zwar... Was sieht man da so für Dinge? Man hat links unten von... welche Taste ist es? Na, von links, von A1 bis rechts vom SZ sind alle Tasten durchbelegt mit direkten Aktionen. Die braucht man auch im Kampf, weil die passieren dann instant, wenn man draufdrückt. Ansonsten hat man noch mehr so eine Art Icons, wo man sich irgendwas drauflegen kann, ob irgendwie mein Magier jetzt Wasser trinken soll oder sein Mana-Diamant irgendwie sich erneut beizaubern soll oder ob ich den Gegner jetzt in den Schaf verwandeln will. Das habe ich mir alles auf Tasten gelegt, die ich nicht direkt klicken kann, sondern wo ich schnell mal mit der Maus hinfahren muss, weil die halt nicht so oft vorkommen.
Also man kann sich sozusagen Keyboard-Shortcuts machen, man kann sich so Direkt-Klicke, Icons machen.
Man kann sich Makros irgendwo drauflegen.
Aber es gibt wahrscheinlich auch so komplexe Menüs, wo man dann alles Mögliche rauskriegen kann.
Das Spiel ist so voll von Zeug, das kann man gar nicht alles ins Interface legen. Also manche Sachen muss man sich immer wieder durchklicken. Da gibt es, glaube ich, Leute, die legen sich ihren Bildschirm voll von Klicks irgendwie oder Icons, wo alles schon drauf fertig ist mit Makros. Und ich bin eher, ich will ja die Gegend sehen und nicht irgendwie lauter Interface-Elemente. Und deswegen habe ich es bei mir relativ dünn besiedelt.
Da hat jeder auch so einen anderen Stil.
Ja, klar. So wie beim OS auch, da gibt es lauter Leute, sich irgendwie Zusatztools installieren und das auch jedes Mal wieder neu machen. Und dann gibt es Leute, die eher so plane spielen und das so lassen, wie es ist. Aber ja, das ist halt Geschmackssache.
Und naja, was muss man denn jetzt tun?
Na, wenn du Level 1 bist, der Unterschied zwischen Level 1 und Level 2 ist halt die Anzahl deiner Erfahrungen, also im Englischen Experience. Und da gibt es Experience Points. Und von Level 1 zu Level 2 brauchst du halt ganz wenig, um irgendwie zum nächsten Level zu kommen. Und du kriegst Erfahrungspunkte, wenn du, ja, Gegner killst, was auch immer ein Gegner ist. Also man muss erstmal sagen, dass in der Welt rennen halt Tiere rum. Zum Beispiel die bösen Tiere, die sind halt immer rot gekennzeichnet. Das heißt, wenn du in deren Nähe kommst, greifen die dich an von ganz alleine.
Rot gekennzeichnet heißt das so ein Aura oder was?
Rot gekennzeichnet heißt, die sind dir feindlich gesinnt.
Wie sind die gekennzeichnet? Die haben ja so einen roten Punkt auf dem Kopf oder was?
Wenn du sie anklickst, dann ist der Text rot. Oder die Beschreibung unten, wenn du so mit der Maus rüberfährst, ohne anklicken, dann wäre die auch rot. Man erkennt das. Und dann gibt es auch Tiere, die sind gelb, die sind neutral, die würden dich nicht angreifen. Aber du kannst sie angreifen, wenn du möchtest. Dann geht der Kampf erst dann los, oder die Feindschaft. Und dann gibt es auch Grüne, andere Allianzer, nämlich alle anderen Allianzer, wenn du einer bist. Die sind halt grün, die kann man nicht angreifen.
Tiere, also nicht nur Tiere, sondern auch alle anderen Mitstreiter.
Die Horde zum Beispiel ist eigentlich immer rot, aber dann gibt es noch so Spezialwelten, da sind die blau, da kann man die nicht angreifen, außer die greifen zuerst an. Also wenn du Level 60 bist, dann bist du der totale Überflieger. Dann könntest du natürlich dort in die Gegend gehen, wo die Horde Level-1-Spieler geboren werden. Die könntest du natürlich andauernd alle umpusten. Kannst du aber nicht, weil die sind blau gekennzeichnet. Du kannst die nur killen, wenn die dich zuerst angreifen. Und die würden natürlich einen Teufel tun, einen 60er zu schlagen. Deswegen kannst du nichts machen gegen die, weil die nicht...
Verstehe. Das ist so eine Art Schutzmechanismus im Programm, um da zu verhindern, dass das alles auswacht.
Dass die höherstufigen die kleinenstufigen Spieler killen.
Ab wie viel Levelunterschied?
Das ist pro Karte bestimmt. Also die Anfangskarte der Horde, da kannst du als Allianzler niemanden direkt killen, außer er fängt an. Dann kannst du natürlich weitermachen. Weil es kann ja auch sein, dass da gerade ein Sechziger rumläuft in dieser Karte, also ein Sechziger Hordler. Dann kannst du den auch nicht killen als Sechziger Allianzler. Aber wenn er anfängt, dann kannst du dich schon wehren.
Aber was heißt jetzt Karte? Also es gibt diese gesamte Welt. Wie groß muss man sich die vorstellen? Also wie groß ist diese Welt?
Größe ist ja relativ. Also die Welt, die alte, ich beschreibe erst mal die alte zur neueren Komma später, ist aufgeteilt in zwei Kontinente, die durch Schiffe verbunden sind. Und diese beiden Kontinente sind jeweils wieder unterteilt in Maps. Und zwischen den Maps, habe ich letztens auch noch mal gelesen, das Wort dafür ist Zoning, gibt es bei World of Warcraft nicht. Weil bei anderen Spielen ist es wohl so, wenn man von einer Map in die nächste geht, dann kommt irgendwie ein Ladeschirm und dann wird angezeigt, dass man jetzt sozusagen in eine neue Zone kommt. Bei WoW gibt es das nicht, sondern du läufst von einer Map direkt in die nächste durch, es gibt keine Grenze. Und wie soll man diese Größe dieser Karte beschreiben?
Aber man sieht sozusagen dann immer auch nur diese eine Karte, man wechselt sozusagen einen anderen Teilbereich und dann hat man den immer im Blick.
Eine Karte ist so, wenn du zum Beispiel in der Wüste läufst, dann wechselst du ganz langsam über in zum Beispiel in den Dschungel und die nächste wäre dann wieder ein Nadelwald und so oder mit Schnee.
Wie groß ist so eine Karte?
Ja, wie soll man jetzt Größe definieren? Wenn ich da jetzt so zu Fuß lang läufle, sagen wir mal, du müsstest fünf Minuten laufen.
Fünf Minuten rennt man durch eine Karte und...
Vielleicht auch länger, ich bin mir halt nicht sicher, wenn ich schon lange nicht mehr gelaufen bin.
Okay, Gefühlsache. Und jetzt mal so, wie viele Karten kann man so durchlaufen, um von unten nach oben durchzumarschieren? Also wenn ich jetzt wirklich so durch einen Kontinent von unten nach oben durchlatsche, bin ich dann Tag und Nacht unterwegs?
Also ich weiß, dass man auf dem einen Kontinent, wenn man von einem ganz oberen Punkt zum ganz unteren fliegt, weil es gibt so eine Art Taxiservice, so von bestimmten Stellen zu bestimmten anderen Stellen, also Flugpunkte nennt sich das, dann fliegt man 20 Minuten. Und das Fliegen ist echt reichlich schneller als Laufen und auch reichlich schneller als Reiten.
Also man wäre wahrscheinlich schon den ganzen Tag länger unterwegs.
Also du läufst von der untersten Karte zur obersten, bist bestimmt irgendwie eine Stunde oder eine Dreiviertel unterwegs.
Aber es hat ja auch nochmal Breite und man kann auch sowieso nicht die ganze Zeit laufen, weil irgendwann wird man wahrscheinlich von irgendwas verhackstückt.
Also die Gegner sind umso aggressiver gegen dich, umso größer der Level-Abstand ist. Also wenn du als Level 1 irgendwie in der Nähe eines Level 10 kommst, der riecht dich förmlich. Wenn du als Level 60 an einem Level 10 vorbeiläufst, dann musst du schon echt über ihn drüber laufen, dass er dich haut. Also du kannst knapp vorbeigehen und der tut dir nichts. Aber der Level 1, der wird über 20 Meter Entfernung angesprungen. Das ist irgendwie so der Agro-Range oder weiß ich auch nicht, wie man das so nennt, der Agro-Bereich.
Also das auf jeden Fall World of Warcraft macht so den Eindruck, als ob es ziemlich gefintunt ist, weil eine ganze Menge Leute scheinen da ja sehr glücklich zu sein. Zehn Millionen Online-Spieler ist ja nicht gerade wenig. Wie viele Server sind das so? Also wie viele sind dann auf einem Server drauf? Mit wie vielen Leuten teilt man sich real so eine Welt?
Also früher war es, glaube ich, so 6.000 bis 10.000 oder so. Da inzwischen durch die Erweitung ein dritter Kontinent dazugekommen ist, konnten sehr mehr Leute irgendwie aufteilen, weil ich glaube zwischen den Kontinenten steht schon ein Zoning. Man kann nicht von einem Kontinent zum anderen laufen. Das sind wahrscheinlich einzelne Rechner bei denen im Hosting. Und deswegen sind mehr User pro Welt jetzt erlaubt. Ich würde mal sagen 20.000 oder so. 15.000, 20.000. Da rücken wir auch immer nicht so richtig mit Zahlen raus.
Krass. Aber auf jeden Fall viele tausend Leute, die potentiell hinter dem Busch hervorspringen könnten und einmal irgendwie Stress machen. Also ich meine, es geht aber jetzt doch nicht nur ums Umbringen. Also es geht auch hier nur darum, da Leute zu töten.
Nein, man kann natürlich diese Erfahrungspunkte nicht nur durch das einfache Umbringen von Wildtieren oder anderen Gegnern, die da so rumschwirren bekommen, sondern auch, dort gibt es sogenannte Questgeber, die haben immer so ein gelbes Ausrufezeichen über dem Kopf schweben. Da kannst du dann hingehen. Das heißt, der hat eine Aufgabe für dich. Die kannst du dir geben lassen. Die ist dann in so einem Art Logbuch drin, dass du diese Aufgabe hast. Und der sagt dann, naja, wir haben hier Probleme in der Gegend. Da ist natürlich auch dann schon alles ein bisschen rollenspielmäßig. Wir haben hier in der Gegend Probleme mit irgendwie den Wildwölfen. Dort im Norden. Und wenn du mir zehn Stück davon killen kannst, dann kriegst du hier so ein bisschen Gold. Und wir haben irgendwie hier neue Handschuhe für dich. Und dann kannst du losziehen, killst die zehn Wölfe, kriegst ein bisschen Erfahrungspunkte, dann gehst du zurück. Bist du fertig mit deiner Aufgabe, sagst dem Typen hier, ich hab das jetzt gemacht. Und dann gibt der dir noch ein bisschen Gold. Oder bei Level 1 ist dann eher Kupfer irgendwie. Und dann kriegst du vielleicht noch Handschuhe dafür. Und du bist vielleicht besser als deine eigene, die du schon hast. Und damit wertest du dann deine Figur auf.
Das heißt, man verdient Geld im Wesentlichen durch das Erfüllen dieser Quests. Oder indem man jemanden ausraubt, wahrscheinlich.
Na ja, ausrauben geht nicht.
Ach echt nicht? Man kann nicht Leute überfallen, die ihnen das Geld abnehmen?
Na du kannst sie killen und ihnen das Geld abnehmen.
Na ja, dann geht das doch.
Aber nur wenn die tot sind. Ich glaube, ein Schurke kann die auch so ausrauben. Der kann die so ein bisschen bestellen schon vorher. Aber Geld kriegst du, indem du die killst oder indem du die Quests abgibst, dann kriegst du Geld. Oder es gibt dann noch, in der Gegend sind irgendwie, kannst du Herze abbauen oder Blümchen pflücken, das gehört dann zu den Berufen. Vielleicht können wir da später noch einsteigen und die kannst du einsammeln und dann später verkaufen.
Aber im Wesentlichen kriegt man also Geld durch das Erfüllen von diesen Aufgaben. Wie viele Aufgaben liegen so herum? Ist das so eine seltene Sache, die man ab und zu mal findet?
Nee, das ist das A und O des ganzen Spiels.
Das heißt, da wird man fast erschlagen mit.
Also pro Map sind vielleicht 40-50 Quests oder so.
40-50? Okay, die jedem Affen stehen.
Also insgesamt gibt es so ein paar tausend Quests.
Was gibt es da noch für Quests? Vielleicht gibt es noch ein paar andere Beispiele, was man da so machen muss?
Na einmal gibt es halt so, geh mal los und töt mal 10 Bölfe, die da so rumlungern. Dann gibt es auch, geh mal los und töte genau diesen Einzelnen, weil 10 Bölfe, da kann man sich ja ausruhen. Du kannst die mehr am Norden killen oder die mehr am Süden irgendwo, wo du sie halt findest, killst du denen und dann zählt das als einen Kill. Aber wenn der Questgeber sagt, du sollst genau diese Figur killen, die es nur einmal auf der Karte gibt, dann musst du sie halt suchen, wo die ist. Und das ist halt ein bisschen schwerer. Meistens sind einzelne Kills auch so ein bisschen schwerer, weil du halt nur einer hast. Dafür musst du dich ein bisschen mehr anstrengen. Dann gibt es auch Quests, wo du es halt nicht alleine schaffst, sondern wo du zwei oder drei oder fünf Leute brauchst. Dann gibt es, wo du bestimmte Sachen einsammeln sollst, die irgendwie dagegen verteilt sind. Du musst irgendwie Eier einsammeln oder Eier kaputt machen oder du musst irgendwie also alles Mögliche.
Gibt es auch so richtige Rätsel oder so Intelligent-Tests oder nicht?
So wirklich.
Ich meine, aus anderen Adventures kennt man das ja, dass man so richtig so Aufgaben lösen muss, geheim Schlüssel oder so.
Ja, mit Schlüssel gibt es auch, aber es sind keine Rätsel, würde ich nicht sagen.
Okay, das heißt, es geht schon eigentlich immer so ein bisschen auch um dieses Rollenspiel tatsächlich. Ich bewege mich in der Welt und tue Dinge, die ich sozusagen in einer scheinbar realen Welt auch tun könnte.
So, wie es halt eine Fantasy-Welt ist.
Na klar.
Also relativ, man könnte sagen, es sind relativ stupide und wiederholen sich.
Okay, was kann ich jetzt mit meinem Geld machen?
Mit deinem Geld kannst du dir auch das...
Heißt das Gold? Also es gibt nur Gold.
Die Einheit da ist irgendwie Gold. Es gibt ja mal einen Club, der sich darüber ein bisschen echauffiert oder lustig macht, weil ich sage immer, ich habe schon 100 Gold. Und dann meint er, nein, da fehlt aber irgendwie was. Man müsste dann vielleicht sagen, ich habe 100 Gold taler oder so. Aber da das nur als Gold, Kupfer und Silber angezeigt wird, ist halt das in der Umgangssprache so. 100 Kupfer sind ein Silber und 100 Silber sind ein Gold.
Ich habe 100 Gold.
Ich habe 3800.
3800 Gold. Und was machst du damit?
Ich spare gerade für das schnelle Flug-Mount. Also ein Mount ist irgendwie, bei dem man aufsitzen kann. Das erste Pferd in World of Warcraft wurde immer Mount genannt. Also aus einer englischen Version. Aber die deutsche Version ist stark eingedeutscht, nur waren sie ein bisschen hinterher. Und dann gibt es das schnelle Reit-Pferd, also ein Epic-Mount. Und jetzt gibt es ein Flugtier. Und jetzt gibt es noch ein schnelles Flugtier. Und darauf spare ich gerade das normale Flugtier. Und jetzt brauche ich noch das schnelle. Das kostet 5.000 Gold. Jetzt kommen wir schon wieder auf die Erweiterung, die es gibt seit einem Jahr. In dem dritten Kontinent kann man auch fliegen. Da ist die 3D-Karte von Blizzard so gestaltet worden, dass man auch fliegen kann.
Also kann man auch selber fliegen?
Ja, selber fliegen, genau. Nicht die fertige Flugstrecke, sondern man kann wirklich selber fliegen.
Wie meinst du das, nicht die fertige Flugstrecke?
In einer alten Welt konnte man an bestimmten Flugpunkten von einer Karte zur nächsten fliegen. Da konntest du sagen, du bist hingegangen und hast gesagt, ich will jetzt genau zu dem anderen Flugpunkt fliegen. Aber du konntest es nicht aussuchen.
Also mehr so ein Teleporter?
Ja, zu bestimmten Stellen, die schon vorgegeben waren. Und jetzt mit dem Flugmount kann man selber von überall nach überall fliegen.
Jetzt mit diesem Vieh oder man fliegt selbst?
Na, mit diesem Vieh. Man zaubert es aus der Tasche. Und dann ist es da. So wie das Pferd oder welche Tiger gab es auch so.
Ist das so ein Flugsaurier-artiges oder Albatross-Airlines, wo man sich da eine Sorteinbose setzt?
Da gibt es ganz verschiedene. Da gibt es Drachen und ich habe so eine Mischung zwischen Adler und Tiger. Vorne Adler, hinten Tiger. So ein Mischding.
Du sparst aber auf was Tolleres.
Na, erstmal auf was Schnelleres. Sieht dann gleich blöd aus, bloß dass sie eine Rüstung drum hat und viel schneller ist. Und dann gibt es natürlich so ganz seltene Mounts, die muss man sich dann irgendwo holen. Da kann ich ja mal meine Story erzählen. Und zwar vor anderthalb Jahren hatte ich halt ein schnelles Pferd. Und da habe ich aber gelesen, dass man, wenn man eine bestimmte Quest irgendwie so ein sieben-, achthundertmal wiederholt, kriegt man einen Winterspring-Säbelzahntiger. Und der ist ganz selten, weil niemand hat Bock drauf, eine Quest achthundertmal zu wiederholen, weil es dauert so sechs bis acht Wochen. Ich habe das halt nebenbei so gemacht, bin auch ganz gut vorwärtsgekommen.
Und was war das?
Ach so ein Typ, der sagt dir, kill drei davon, drei davon, drei davon, dann musstest du zwei, drei Minuten durch die Gegend reiten, musstest du killen, musstest du zurück reiten und wieder abgeben und das immer so rei um.
Und das hast du dann sechs Wochen lang gemacht?
Sechs Wochen lang, ja. Nein.
Doch. Und dann machtest du auf einmal blüm.
Na dann hatte ich bei dem Typ, der hat eine eigene Fraktion, man kann bei der Fraktion, da gibt es ganz, ganz viele in dem Spiel, kann man seinen Ruf verbessern.
Was heißt das bei dem Typ?
Na der Questgeber war ein Typ.
Achso.
Der stand da auch so.
Also das ist ein anderer Spieler?
Nein, nein, nein.
Das ist so eine Fickummer?
Das ist ein sogenannter NPC, ein Non-Player-Charakter. Non-Player-Charakter, genau. Der steht da immer rum und der hat eine eigene Fraktion, obwohl er ja nur einer ist dort, aber...
Was ist eine Fraktion?
Eine Fraktion ist die... da gibt es ja noch ganz viele Rassen und Gemeinschaften im Spiel, wie soll man das nennen? Ja, alles NPCs halt. Also von Blizzard erstellte er die Orks und Gruppen. Klicken, wie auch immer, aber im Spiel halt schon fertig. Und der Typ stellte halt seine eigene da. Er selbst hatte eine eigene Fraktion. Und bei der musstest du deinen Ruf verbessern. Und das geht von neutral über freundlich, wohlwollend, ehrfürchtig, oder nee, wohlwollend, respektvoll, ehrfürchtig. Und wenn du bei dem Typen ehrfürchtig wurdest, dann hat er dir beigebracht, wie man halt auf einem Winterspring Säbelzahntiger reiten kann. Und dann konntest du den Tiger bei ihm auch gleich kaufen. Und das hast du halt erst bekommen, wenn du ehrfürchtig warst. Und um ehrfürchtig zu werden, musstest du diese Quests wiederholen, bis du deinen Ruf irgendwie bei ihm hattest. Bis er dich sozusagen toll genug fand.
Weil du irgendwie 800-mal in den Wald gelaufen bist und irgendwelche Stinktiere rausgeholt hast.
Genau, er war so ein anderer Typ, den man killen musste. Du hast natürlich nebenbei ohne Ende Geld verdient, weil du immer diese Typen gekillt hast. Die haben ja auch Geld dabei, dann hatten sie Stoff dabei. Ich war sowieso Schneider, es gibt auch Berufe, ich war Schneider. Da brauchte ich diesen Stoff auch sowieso. Und das hat sich nebenbei auch für andere Sachen gelohnt. Aber es war schon sechs Wochen immer mal wieder dorthin. Also es ist schon bekloppter.
Wie viel Zeit hast du mit World of Warcraft verbracht?
Inzwischen sind es, glaube ich, so 125 Tage. Also mal acht Stunden. Ich habe mal ausgerechnet, das sind anderthalb Arbeitsjahre.
128 vollständige Tage durchgehendes Spiel. Also sozusagen alle 24 Stunden. Das heißt, ich teile das jetzt mal durch acht Stunden. 128 Tage mal 24 durch. Das ist 384 Tage, acht Stunden. Hammer. Also, wenn ich jetzt mal von der Fünf-Tage-Woche ausgehe. Oh Gott, das ist ja unfassbar. Ja, reden wir nicht drüber. Also, du hast auf jeden Fall sehr viel Zeit verbracht damit.
Ja, oft ist es ja auch an und dann ist man gar nicht dabei. Also, das ist, zwei, drei Tage kann man bestimmt abziehen.
Was hält dich da so drin gefangen? Also, was lässt einen da nicht los?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Also, am Anfang hat der Christoph ja mich überreden wollen, dass ich das spiele. Und ich habe mich immer geweigert und gewehrt. Und er wollte immer vorbeikommen, ich muss mal zeigen. Und ich sage, nee, keinen Bock und so. Und dann kam er irgendwann, hat es mir gezeigt. Und dann haben wir eine Figur erstellt für mich halt, mein Magier. Deswegen auch mit dem blöden Namen. Ich konnte nicht wissen, dass es was Ernstes wird. Dann habe ich ein bisschen gezockt. Und dann ist einem langweilig irgendwie mal vielleicht. Und dann macht man an seinem Figürchen weiter. Das ist halt auch so ein Verbesserungsding. Man will sich ja immer verbessern und man will irgendwie vorwärts kommen im Leben. Und das Gleiche gilt natürlich auch für meinen Magier. Und der kann halt immer besser werden. Dann spielt man wieder ein bisschen, dann kriegt man einen besseren Level. Wenn man einen besseren Level kriegt, lernt man wieder einen neuen Zauberspruch, also als Magier. Die anderen Klassen lernen dann andere Sachen. Und so kommt dann eins zum anderen irgendwie. Das ist so ein Verbesserungsding. Das ist ein Upgrade-Ding. So wie ich gerne auch mein OS immer alles irgendwie auf dem neuesten Stand halte. So ist auch mein Magier, ich versuche den immer zu verbessern, so wie es irgendwie geht.
Hat das dann so Tamagotchi-Qualitäten?
Das ist ein Aspekt, wie Blizzard die Leute hält. Die haben ja ganz viele Sachen, wie sie versuchen, die Leute an diesem Spiel zu halten. Das ist ja auch...
Aber man kann doch auch sterben. Und dann ist man gleich wieder am Leben.
Na, nicht ganz. Wenn man stirbt, gehen erst mal jeder Rüstungsgegenstand, den man hat, und Waffen und so, haben so eine gewisse Haltbarkeit. So einen gewissen Wert. Und immer wenn man stirbt, sinkt der um 10%. Also vom Gesamten. Also, sagen wir mal, der Schattenflamme habe ich, hat irgendwie einen Haltbarkeitswert von 100. Wenn ich sterbe auf 90, nochmal sterbe 80 und so weiter. Und wenn ich zehnmal gestorben bin, ist er bei null. Dann ist er wie, als wenn ich es nicht mehr habe. Und dann muss man sich halt reparieren lassen. Das heißt, Sterben kostet auf lange Sicht Geld. Ah, okay.
Wie häufig bist du so gestorben in der ganzen Zeit?
Den Zähler gibt es nicht. Aber tausende Male.
Tausende Male?
Mehrere tausende Male.
Also hast du auch viel von deinen Dingen auch konkret eingebüßt?
Ich musste immer wieder reparieren lassen. Das kostet halt Geld. Aber Gegenstände kann man nicht verlieren. Also nicht durch Sterben. Das geht nicht. Es kostet nur Geld. Wenn die dann runter sind irgendwann, muss man sich reparieren lassen, dass die wieder da sind. Oder man kann sie auch schon vorher reparieren lassen, damit es nicht gar nicht erst dazu kommt.
Okay, aber man versucht schon, das Risiko des Sterbens......
zu minimieren, weil der eigentliche Faktor in dem Spiel ist ja die Zeit. Weil das hat man ja nur begrenzt. Und Sterben kostet einen halt Zeit, weil du stirbst auf der Karte an einem gewissen Punkt und der Friedhof ist vielleicht genau am anderen Ende der Karte. Und dann musst du von diesem Friedhof bis zu deinem Leichnam als Geist sozusagen hinrennen und dich dann dort wiederbeleben lassen. Und das kostet halt Zeit.
Ah, man rennt mit seinem eigenen Geist sozusagen......
vom Friedhof wieder zur Leiche.
Dann ist man nur so ein Schattenwesen und...... man sieht alles, aber kann nichts berühren und so weiter.
Genau, genau, genau. Man kann auch nicht arbeiten, nicht zaubern.
Sieht man selbst die anderen Geister, wie sie an einem vorbeilatschen?
Ich glaube, die anderen Geister sieht man schon, aber man sieht die anderen Spieler nicht. Man sieht erst dann welche, wenn man an seiner Leiche ist, dann würde man andere Spieler sehen.
Ach so, als Geist sieht man die Spieler nicht, aber die anderen Geister? Und sieht man als Spieler die Geister? Okay. Okay, das heißt, es ist auch wirklich langweilig, dann dieses Zurücklaufen.
Horrible.
Ist noch mal eine extra Strafe.
Nein, eine Zeitstrafe. Bestraft wird man durch Zeit. Weil durch was sollen die ja sonst bestrafen?
Ja, stimmt. Kostet ja auch Geld.
Ja, die wollen ja, dass man spielt. Gold wegnehmen könnten sie auch machen, aber das passiert ja dadurch, dass die Rüstung halt irgendwie an zehn Prozent verliert. Und hauptsächlich wird man bestraft, dass man wieder hinreist. Ist einfach nervig und man will es deswegen vermeiden. Weil sonst könnte man ja so andauernd sterben. Aber ja.
Was ist denn, wenn man nicht online ist? Was ist passiert denn dann mit einem...
Na, sagen wir mal, wir stehen jetzt so mitten auf der Straßenkreuzung und loggen uns aus, dann würden die anderen Spieler sehen, dass dort eine Figur steht, die plötzlich langsam so in drei Sekunden so unsichtbar wird und dann weg ist.
Ah, das heißt, man verpufft und dann ist man aber auch wirklich nirgendswo.
Genau. Und wenn man sich einlögt, kommt man dann genau der Stelle wieder raus. Aber man kann sich nicht ausloggen, wenn man gerade im Kampf ist. Du kannst natürlich dein Spiel abschießen und einfach ausmachen. Aber wenn du dich dann wieder eidloggst, kannst du auch davon ausgehen, dass du dann tot bist, wenn dich gerade einer angegriffen hat.
Achso, man macht auch dann, das heißt, man spielt auch wirklich die Stelle weiter, wo man aufgehört hat. Also auch wenn man da von fünf Personen umgeben ist. Aber das kann ja eigentlich nicht sein, das ist ja noch so ein Multiplayer-Game. Da laufen ja noch ganz viele andere Leute rum, die sind ja dann unter Umständen weg. Wie? Du meintest ja gerade, man kann sich nicht ausloggen, wenn man im Kampf ist. Warum? Weil wenn man wieder zurückkommt, dann immer noch der Kampf ist?
Nein. Weil man kann sich nicht ausloggen, wenn man im Kampf ist. Man könnte höchstens sein Spiel abschießen, dass man einfach nicht weitermacht. Aber für die anderen bleibt man halt dort stehen und stirbt.
Achso, man kann sich nicht regulär ausblenden, sondern würde man in dem Moment offline gehen, dann steht man, als würde man nichts tun und dann ist man tot.
Genau. Das heißt auch, wenn man spielt und man kämpft gerade und das Leben ist schon irgendwie, oder es ging gerade los, man hat noch 90% Leben, weil die auf einen einkloppen und alles läuft super und man hat hier den berühmten DSL-Disconect. Dann lockt man sich halt ganz schnell wieder ein und dann, wenn man Glück hat, ist man noch nicht ganz tot und kriegt es vielleicht noch gebacken. DSL-Disconect, das ist für dich. Wundert mich auch, dass die es bei Blizzard sich noch nichts haben dagegen einfällen lassen.
Was sollen wir dagegen tun?
Na, die Verbindung von alleine gleich sofort wieder aufbauen.
Ach so, das machen sie nicht? Das ist ja doof.
Da steht dann Serververbindung unterbrochen und dann darfst du dich wieder einloggen.
Das kriegt Skype immer ganz gut hin. Fällt mir gerade so ein. Wundert mich selber immer.
Also bisher machen die dabei bei Blizzard nichts.
Ich finde, man sollte mal die Horde und die Allianz gemeinsam gegen die DSL-Provider in Deutschland los schicken, damit die den mal ordentlichen Dampf machen. Ich habe gerade erst vor ein paar Tagen wieder eine Support-Torte zusammengeschrien, weil das irgendwie mir wieder etwas erzählt hat von wegen, ja, wir müssen das tun. Da wollte ich auch so was, das heißt, wir müssen das tun. Ja, mein Vorgesetzter hat mir gesagt, lassen Sie sich verarschen von Ihrem Vorgesetzten, erzählen Sie mal was Ordentliches.
Da ist ich ganz aufgeregt geworden. Weil bei Alice gibt es wohl demnächst auch Fest-Adressen, da müssen wir mal gucken.
Das war Alice und ich habe gefragt, ob sie bei Fest-Adressen...
Gibt es aber jetzt.
Ja, aber sie haben immer noch die Disconnect. Genau, das habe ich auch gesagt. Na, ich habe gesagt, tut mir leid, ich werde leider die Kunde. Nein, aber dafür kriegst du eine Fest-IP-Adresse. Aber Disconnect, das müssen Sie machen, meinte sie. Naja, aber das ist nicht unser Thema DSL, da können wir noch mal drüber anders raten. Da wollte ich auch irgendwann noch mal eine Sendung zu machen zu DSL in Deutschland, wo ich auch mal eine Sendung machen wollte. Aber das flüchtet mir immer mein potenzieller Gesprächspartner zu dem Thema, mal gucken, vielleicht kriege ich ihn irgendwann noch mal eingefangen. Nun ja, wir waren ja aber bei World of Warcraft. Du hast ja gesagt, also zwei Sachen wollte ich noch mal hinterfragen. Also erstmal diese Ausrüstungsgeschichte, was für Ausrüstung braucht man, was will man haben und muss man sich da alles kaufen, von der Socke über die Unterhose?
Also alle Rassen und Klassen haben die gleichen Ausrüstungsslots, wo sie so eine Art Wäsche reinmachen können. Für den Kopf gibt es etwas, das wechselt dann von einer Mütze zur Kappe, zur Brille, also alles, was den Kopf betrifft. Dann gibt es Halsschmuck, dann gibt es etwas für die Schultern, dann gibt es so eine Art Robe oder für die Brust ist es. Dann gibt es die Hose, Stiefel, gibt es Armenschützer, Handschuhe, dann gibt es zwei Plätze für Schmuck und zwei Plätze für Ringe. Ich hoffe, ich habe jetzt nichts ausgelassen.
Zwei Plätze heißt, man kann sozusagen nur zwei Ringe gleichzeitig tragen, nicht drei.
Genau. Man kann ja mehr dabei haben, aber da muss man halt wechseln und man kann auch wiederum nicht im Kampf wechseln. Also muss dann halt, wenn man sieht, da ist ein Gegner, der ist ganz anfällig gegen eine bestimmte Zauberart, dann setzt man schnell vor den Ring auf, der genau diese Zauberart irgendwie pusht oder verbessert und dann greift man den natürlich damit an. Ist aber ziemlich aufwendig im Großen und Ganzen. Also ich spiele immer mit der gleichen Ausstattung, ist nur ganz selten, wo ich mal absichtlich hin und her.
Aber es gibt schon so Jean Leure. Das heißt, das ist das, wofür man wirklich das Geld braucht?
Also mit dieser Jean Leure kann ich ja eine Sache erzählen und zwar gibt es oft, als Schmuck habe ich eine Karotte und zwar die Karotte macht mich beim Reiten 3% schneller. Wenn ich halt irgendwo hinreiten will, dann ziehe ich natürlich diese Karotte an. Es gibt jetzt auch schon was mit 10%, aber ich habe nur die Karotte. Ja, so eine Karotte, weil man hat doch eigentlich ein Pferd gehabt. Ich habe jetzt halt meinen coolen Tiger, aber das mit den 3% geht halt trotzdem, weil mein Tiger irgendwie auch auf Karotten abgeht.
Ach so, der hältst du denn die Karotte?
Nee, ich ziehe die an, anstelle von irgendeinem anderem Schmuck, wo ich mehr Zauberdamage habe, ziehe ich halt diese Karotte an.
Ach, der hältst die Karotte dann irgendwie vor den Tiger?
Nee, optisch sieht man da nichts. Man zieht die so als, die kommt in so einen Schmuckplatz rein. Und jedenfalls, wenn dann irgendein Kampf kommt, dann kämpfe ich oft mit Karotte, weil ich vergesse das scheiß Ding wieder auszuziehen. Und deswegen muss man da ein bisschen aufpassen, was man macht.
Was heißt, du kämpfst mit Karotte?
Na, anstelle, dass ich halt einen Schmuck drin habe, der meine Zauberfähigkeiten verbessert, habe ich halt eine Karotte an, die mich nur drei Prozent schneller macht, was ich im Kampf überhaupt nicht nutzen kann.
Okay, verstehe.
Genau, deswegen muss man mit dem Jonglieren ein bisschen aufpassen. Aber dafür gibt es wieder so Skripte-Tools, die dafür sorgen, dass wenn man auf einen Mount steigt, das automatisch die Karotte anzieht kurz vorher und wenn man wieder absteigt, dass automatisch die Karotte wieder zurück wechseln.
Das ist dieses Skripting-Feature, das heißt, man kann das Spiel auch selbst programmieren, also zahlen bestimmte Funktionalitäten automatisieren.
Man kann nicht alles automatisieren, also man kann ihn nicht selber kämpfen lassen oder bestimmte Sachen langlaufen lassen, aber man kann schon mit dem, was Blizzard zur Verfügung stellt, irgendwie so eine Sache machen, wie wenn ich diese Tasse drücke, dann ziehe ich automatisch das an und steige auf meinen Mount und so, also bestimmte Sachen in Folge ablaufen lassen, die man sich auch so klicken könnte, aber man kann nicht zu viel machen.
Worin scriptet man das?
Das ist auch in diesem Lua programmiert.
Lua, das ist noch eine relativ neue Scriptsprache.
Ja, ich habe mir das noch nie genauer angeguckt, aber die ganzen Kitties, die fahren da voll drauf ab und werden alles Lua-Programmierer jetzt.
Das soll wohl ganz cool sein, aber ich habe auch noch nicht so richtig, es arbeitet auch so mit Bytecode und ist glaube ich auch objektorientiert und ein bisschen funktional und so, aber ich habe es auch noch nicht so richtig durchgegeben.
Also da gibt es tausende Sachen, weil es ja ein komplexes Spiel ist und da geht alles Mögliche.
Okay, und diese Berufe, die du erwähnt hast?
Na, Berufe gibt es halt, wie viele gibt es denn eigentlich, also ich bin Schneider, dann gibt es noch den Alchemisten, dann gibt es den Blumensammler, dann gibt es den Erzabbauer, dann gibt es den Lederverarbeiter und dann gibt es noch den Verzauberer, demnächst, in einer noch nächsten Erweiterung, die in ein paar Monaten kommt, gibt es einen Schriftgelehrten und es gibt noch einen, der, wie heißt der, na, der so, hm, hab ich vergessen, Steinchen machen kann, die man in seine Waffen reinkriegt.
Aber wie wird man denn?
Das wählt man sich einfach aus am Anfang. Man kann, wie zwei Berufe kann man sich auswählen von diesen ganzen verschiedenen und, hm, die hat man dann automatisch drauf oder? Ich hab das mit dem TeamSpeak programmiert und hat nicht, weil bei TeamSpeak gibt's glaube ich zwei verschiedene Codecs und zwar auch einmal GSM ist es und einmal diesen Speaks Codec und die Mac-Version kann nur diesen Speaks. Deswegen heißt der auch TeamSpeaks mit X hinten. Und die originalen TeamSpeak-Leute haben irgendwie da ein bisschen rumgezickt und dann haben sie sich am Ende wohl so geeinigt, dass der Mac-Kline von dem TeamSpeaks bei den originalen TeamSpeak-Leuten irgendwie downloadbar ist und er auch nicht mehr daran weitercodeet. Aber die originalen TeamSpeak-Leute haben nie selbst irgendwie, glaube ich, mal eine Mac-Version rausgebracht. Also ich habe jetzt in letzter Zeit nicht nachgeguckt, aber ich glaube, dass irgendwie nichts passiert ist.
Das heißt, sie haben das so genommen, wie es ist, und hacken das irgendwie, dass es gerade so eben läuft.
Na, die hätten ihn ja auch gleich weiterarbeiten lassen können oder hätten zumindest ihm ein bisschen Geld bezahlt, dass er weitercodeet oder was auch ist, aber jetzt ist die Mac-Version irgendwie eingestellt und...
Aber es ist kein offenes Protokoll, dieses TeamSpeak, das ist irgendwie undokumentiert. Das kann so schwierig nicht sein, oder? Eigentlich müsste man mal da mal was...
Na, mit Audio und Latenzen und Zeug, ich glaube, so einfach ist das doch alles gar nicht.
Naja, aber so schwer ist das nun auch wieder alles nicht.
Na, guck dir die ganzen Streaming-Geschichten an, wie oft die out of sync sind und alles, also ich denke immer Audio.
Ich halte das nicht für unmöglich. Also, das kann ja mal gemacht werden, weil diese Idee sozusagen Audio so zu haben, wie IRC-Chat, also dass man wirklich so einen Kanal hat, den man einfach joint und dann ist man mit dabei und so und dann vielleicht mit der Möglichkeit, da auch geschlossene Benutzergruppen zu machen. Mein Gott, das ist also jetzt so von der Komplexität, also das Überbau ist sowieso nicht komplex und Audio kriegt man schon auch irgendwie hin, also.
Also eigentlich ist das schon ganz cool mit diesem Teamspeak, also.
Ja, klar, aber ich hätte auch ganz gerne mal einen gepflegten Client, der so mit Features daherkommt und sich irgendwie, ja, na gut, wenn er funktioniert, ist prima, du hast mir jetzt gerade wieder irgendwie noch mit, da musst du aber dann die Beta, die nicht auf der eigentlichen Seite ist.
Mitten in der Programmierung haben sie ihn ausgebremst und deswegen muss man sich die Beta so ein bisschen klicken und nicht die ganz offizielle vorne auf seiner Seite, aber dann hat man also sie war zumindest stabil, ich hatte nie Ärger damit.
Release 408.
Genau.
Muss man sich rausfischen aus dem Internet. Okay, soviel zu Teamspeak vielleicht auch soviel zu World of Warcraft, ich weiß nicht, wir sind jetzt schon über zwei Stunden unterwegs.
Hast du noch Punkte auf deine Liste, die wir schnell abhaken?
Du hast nur eins noch erwähnt, so als zukünftige Erweiterung. Was war da?
Lich King.
Lich King?
Lich King. Ich weiß nicht, wie die Amis das aussprechen. Vielleicht sagen wir Lich King?
Lichy?
Was ist das?
Das ist das Nach The Burning Crusade. Weil alle schon auf Level 70 sind, das ist schon wieder langweilig für mich.
Aber alle sind jetzt seit März oder so, weil die brauchen so einen Monat dann Level 70. Dann brauchen sie noch ein paar Monate, um die Instanzen irgendwie durch zu rocken. Das werden sie wahrscheinlich auch seit August, September. Irgendwie haben sie die alle durchgespielt. Und seitdem machen sie sich noch ein bisschen besser und spielen ihr Zweitkakt. Weil natürlich haben ganz viele Leute den sogenannten Twink. Das ist der Twin-Character, Kurzfassung Twink. Und ja, ich habe schon mal erlebt, dass ich mit einem gespielt habe, der war Twink. Und dann wurden wir von einer Horde angegriffen. Wir waren noch irgendwo im Bereich 60. Und er meinte, das ist aber Schweinerei. Er holt jetzt mal seinen anderen Charakter. Dann hat er einen Siebziger vorgeholt. Dann haben wir die Horde gekillt. Und dann meinte er...
Mit zwei Laptops gleichzeitig gespielt?
Nein, nein, dann haben sie sich mit dem Sechziger ausgelockt und hat seinen Siebziger geholt. Und dann haben wir den gekillt. Und dann meinte er, wenn wir es jetzt nicht geschafft hätten, weil es war ganz schön knapp, dann hätte er seine Hauptfigur geholt. Weil der Siebziger, den er geholt hat, war auch nur so ein nebenbei irgendwie gepflegter. Weil seinen Hauptcharakter mit den richtig geilen Klamotten und Zaubern und was weiß ich nicht alles, den hat er noch gar nicht geholt. Also der hatte drei, anscheinend. Und es gibt Leute, die haben ganz, ganz viele. Und man kann seine Charaktere auch auf eBay verkaufen.
Das heißt, die haben wahrscheinlich 128 Tage Lebenszeit in jeden dieser einzelnen Figuren reingesteckt, oder was?
Ja, ich spiele schon ziemlich lange und über die Zeit verteilt. Das heißt, wenn jetzt einer siebties ist, heißt ja nicht, dass der so lange gespielt hat.
Wie lange braucht man denn so mindestens, um wirklich jetzt so bis siebzig durchzumarschieren?
Na, der jetzt gerade angefangen hat, der hat jetzt in den letzten acht Tagen oder neun sind es jetzt, oder so, hat halt bis Level 20, 21 gespielt.
Aber das geht ja nicht so linear weiter, oder?
Das geht ja exponentiell, genau. Und deswegen braucht er vielleicht, weiß ich nicht, noch mal vier Wochen, bis er sechzig oder siebzig wird. Also ich habe von sechzig bis siebzig, habe ich auch vier Wochen gebraucht oder so.
So Netto-Spielzeit oder so insgesamt Dauer?
Nein, Realzeit. Also Spielzeit habe ich jetzt nicht geguckt, ich weiß nicht.
Und okay, also man muss schon noch ein bisschen Zeit reinstecken, aber man muss jetzt auch nicht unbedingt ein komplettes Jahr seines Lebens abstellen.
Also ich habe auch, wie gesagt, ein Jahr Pause gemacht jetzt und das geht auch ganz gut ohne das Warzorn.
Und dann zackt es dann trotzdem wieder?
Nein, man kommt langsam wieder rein. Aber wie gesagt, das ist ein bisschen langweilig immer zu Questen. Ich würde mir jetzt schon wünschen, demnächst dann auch mal wieder eine Gilde zu kommen, weil dieses Gruppenspiel muss schon sein, weil ohne das macht es wirklich keinen Spaß. Dann ist wirklich irgendwann die langweilige Wiederholung.
Na ja, Chaosradio Express funktioniert sicherlich auch gut als Partnervermittlung. Wir suchen eine Gilde für Denis.
Nee, nee, nee, ich suche mir nicht schon selber. Das haben mich auch schon ganz viele gefragt. Und dann sag ich, die sagen immer, da suchst du eine Gilde und dann sage ich immer nee. Weil die sehen es ja, dass ich keine habe, weil es steht unterm Namen, nicht darunter, in welcher man ist. Und dann sagen sie, wieso nicht? Dann sage ich, ich habe noch einen Job. Und dann verstehen die das schon.
Okay, also du suchst dir irgendwann noch mal eine Gilde, aber wir brauchen jetzt keine Angebote über Chaosradio oder CDE einzusammeln?
Es ist ja auch so, man kommt ja nicht so einfach an jede Gilde. Es ist ja schon so ein bisschen, auch Elite-Gruppen und so weiter, die richtigen Top-Gilden, die würden mich gar nicht, nicht nur nicht nehmen, die würden mich nicht mal angucken.
Bist du so schlecht?
Naja, zurzeit schon. Ich bin halt so ein frischer Siebziger, der jetzt erst 70 geworden ist, wo alle anderen schon im März oder so 70 geworden sind. Das heißt, die hatten schon ein Jahr lang, um ihre Klamotten zu verbessern. Ich hab irgendwie seit zwei, drei Wochen, bin ich 70 und hab noch nicht so viel Zeit gehabt. Das heißt, ich renne noch mit ganz schön alten Zeugs irgendwie rum. Und die Top-Gilden, die sind natürlich alle voll super prima ausgestattet. Und du brauchst schon super prima ausgestattete Leute für den Content, den die spielen. Also die Instanzen, die die machen, da würde ich wahrscheinlich sofort tot umfallen.
Was heißt denn prima ausgestattet? Also man ist sozusagen, also Levels ist nicht alles. Levels ist erst mal nur so der Anfang. Und danach geht es darum, dass man einfach sich geile Klamotten kauft, oder was?
Na vorher auch schon, aber, sagen wir mal, du bist Level 20 und hast eine Klamotte, die für Levels, also die Klamotten haben auch teilweise ein Level, der steht mit dabei, ab wann du die anziehen darfst. Damit so ein Level 1 nicht natürlich mit dem Schwert irgendwie rumbrennt, was der Level 60 hat. Das darf natürlich nicht sein. Deswegen haben die Waffen und Rüstung, haben halt so Levels ab wann die getragen werden dürfen. So, wenn du mit Level 20 halt ein cooles Item findest, was für Level 20 ist, dann ist das natürlich auch nicht so cool, wie wenn er Level 25 ist und ein Item findet, was für ein Level 25 ist. Dann ist das 25 natürlich besser. Und so geht das halt bis 60. Also wenn du bei 60 bist, trägst du halt die Items, die für Level 60 gedacht ist. Und dann gibt es noch einen weiteren Unterschied. Es gibt irgendwie weiße Items, die sind so ganz normal. Dann gibt es grüne, die sind irgendwie, ich weiß nicht wie die heißen, aber dann gibt es noch die blauen, die sind rar. Und dann gibt es die lilenen Items, die sind episch. Und das ist auch nochmal ein Unterschied. Ja, supertoll. Und dann gibt es sozusagen ein Item, was für Level 55 ist und episch, könnte noch besser sein als eins, was ein 60er trägt, was nur grün ist. Das ist halt, wie lange es sozusagen, oder was für tolle Werte es hat, kann man immer noch an dieser Farbe erkennen. Und wenn man Level 70 ist und grüne Items hat, ist man lange nicht so cool wie ein Level-70er mit blauen Items. Und dann gibt es halt noch Level-70 mit epischen Items. Und dann gibt es noch die ganz, ganz ultra seltenen Items. Die sind orange, die heißen, das sind Artefakte. Und die sind, weiß nicht, also um so einzusehen, ich weiß nicht, ich würde mal sagen, jetzt auf dem Server gibt es vielleicht hundert so Items, wahrscheinlich sind es schon mehr. Aber es ist ganz, ganz selten, dass du einen mit so einem Item siehst. Das ist dann auch, da musst du monatelang irgendein Zeug machen und die ganze Gilde muss irgendwie mithelfen, dass dann dieser eine Typ, der das Rezept dafür oder die Anfangsquest oder was auch immer dafür gefunden hat, dass der sein episches Item irgendwie zu Ende kriegt, weil alleine kriegst du es gar nicht hin.
Ja, auf welchem Server gammelst du eigentlich so rum?
Kill jeden heißt der ganz zufällig.
Kill jeden?
Ja, also K-I-L minus J-A-E-D-N.
Okay, da kann man dich finden?
Da kann man dich finden.
Denis X mit dem fliegenden Säbelzahntiger?
Nee, fliegen kann er nicht. Fliegen ist mein neues, mein Säbelzahntiger kann nur reiten.
Ach so, okay, du reitest auf den Säbelzahntiger. Sehr ausführliche Darstellung, tolles Thema. World of Warcraft. Mal gucken, ob es mich auch irgendwann nochmal erwischt, aber... Du hast keine Zeit für sowas. Das ist derzeit nicht zu machen, weil wenn ich das machen würde, gibt es keine Podcasts mehr und ich glaube, da wäre jetzt die Hörerschaft nicht so begeistert von.
Und halbherzig WoW-Spielen macht auch nicht so richtig Spaß.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen. Ich mache auch die Sachen lieber richtig mit Wumm und so. Das mache ich halt gerade das. Aber ich habe darüber geredet. Schön, dass wir mal darüber gesprochen haben. Das ist ja auch ganz gut. Ich habe schon das Gefühl, ich bin auf Level 42 oder so.
Ab Level 40 kann man reiten. Da geht der Spaß richtig los. Das ist wirklich ein Ereignis.
Kein schlechter Einstieg. Super. Das war es. Chaosradio Express Nummer 73. Mal wieder schön lang, nachdem wir auch so einige recht knappe und kurze hatten in der letzten Zeit. Und auch mal ein bisschen weg von der Technik mehr hin zur modernen Digitalkultur und das, was Jugendliche so bewegt. Sehr informativer Podcast vor allem für Eltern, die mal ihre Kinder wieder verstehen wollen, was sie so alles von sich geben.
Also es gibt es auch so Parental Controls. Also man kann das schon so ein bisschen managen. Also Eltern sollten nicht ganz so dagegen sein. Ich habe auch schon mal mit einer Elfjährigen gespielt und dann kamen irgendwie die Mutter, die das so ein bisschen aufpasst und so. Und dann muss man halt sehen, dass Sven, die war auch im Teamspeak und auch in unserer Guild, hat da mitgemacht bei dem schweren Content. Und da muss man sich halt ein bisschen zurückhalten, was man so im Teamspeak so von sich gibt.
Die Flüche etwas eindämmen.
Muss ja ein bisschen jugendfrei sein. Aber die Eltern haben selber auch gespielt. Also es war ganz witzig.
Ah, die hatten Verständnis.
Ja, solange die dabei sind.
Das ist ja auch dann nichts, also ich meine, es gibt ja diese, ich wollte nicht so sehr jetzt auf diese ganze Gewaltspiel-Diskussion eingehen, weil das ist einfach noch mal so ein komplett eigenes Fass, was ich nie aufmachen wollte. Aber grundsätzlich denke ich, dass World of Warcraft auch wieder wirklich ein gutes Beispiel dafür, gut, da kann man irgendwie versinken, da kann man irgendwie seine Abhängigkeit ausbauen, ist klar, aber suchtanfällig sein, ist ja immer das eine. Womit man das dann ausfüllt, ist das andere. Aber World of Warcraft ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr diversifiziertes Spiel, wo man wirklich viel lernen und können muss und auch Fähigkeiten entwickeln muss. Und insbesondere glaube ich in diesem Gildenkontext und auch in diesen stilisierten Kampf-Szenarien geht es ja auch wirklich darum, sich auch in einer Gruppe einzufügen, Teamgeist zu haben, sich zu kundigen.
Ab und zu mal sich zurückhalten und ab und zu mal vorne mit dran zu sein. Vielleicht muss ja auch einer den Leader machen, einer von 40 oder mehrere.
Und da hatte ich auch schon welche, die waren 15.
Da war einer, der war 15. Cody hieß er. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Sendung hört, wahrscheinlich. Aber der war damals eigentlich einer der besten, nicht Gilden-Lieder, aber er hat die Raids geleitet. Die Bosse killten uns und der kannte sich da aus und wusste, wie man es macht. Oder er hat sich reingelesen, hat sich das gemerkt und hat immer gute Anweisungen gegeben, sodass es auch klappt. Ich habe es selber auch mal probiert und es hat nicht so gut geklappt. Auf mich hat keiner gehört. Aber ich habe mich auch nicht so reingelesen. Wenn man ein bisschen wackelt bei seinen Erklärungen, dann kommen andere, die haben es irgendwie meins besser erklären zu müssen und schon macht jeder in dem Raid, was er will. Und dann klappt es halt nicht, weil man braucht wirklich, dass 40 Leute das machen, was einer sagt. Oder zumindest, dass 40 Leute das Gleiche machen, wie auch immer. Und das ist halt nicht so einfach irgendwie. Kannst ja mal in so einen Kindergarten gehen mit 40 Kids und versuchen, die irgendwie geordnet zu kriegen. In der Schule kennt man ja die Lehrerinnen, die ihre Schüler nicht im Griff haben.
Ja, das ist, also 40 ist schon ein starkes Stück.
Die wissen schon, warum die das auf 25 runtergesetzt haben.
Ja, finde ich auch eine etwas gesundere Zahl. Fünf mal fünf finde ich auch irgendwie sinnvoller. Ich weiß nicht, wie sie auf 40 gekommen sind, was weiß ich.
Vielleicht war das User-Interface.
Ich glaube die Zahl acht, die ist ja bei Programmieren manchmal auch ein bisschen verleitend. Du weißt schon so, das bit und das byte.
Aber dann wäre es ja nicht acht mal fünf, sondern acht mal acht.
Das war dann vielleicht dann doch zu viel, keine Ahnung. Ich finde ja fünf, fünf ist ja eine interessante Zahl, gerade was so Gruppenbildung betrifft. Fünf wird gemeinhin ja auch bei den Verschwörungstheoretikern immer so als die Größenordnung angesehen, wo man sozusagen noch genug Meinungsvielfalt hat, aber es auch nicht so groß ist, dass es irgendwie gegeneinander geht. Also man kann sowohl noch als Gruppe arbeiten und Entscheidungen fällen. Das Ganze ist irgendwie überschaubar, aber man ist auch nicht zu wenige. Und das scheint da sicherlich auch eine Rolle gespielt zu haben. Was weiß ich, keine Ahnung. Jetzt das Ganze mal fünf und schon hat man einen Raid und kann loslegen und die Drachen bekämpfen. Und vielleicht seid ihr auch bald mit unterwegs bei World of Warcraft auf irgendeinem dieser zahlreichen Server. Und haut die Drachen tot. Dann wünsche ich euch schon mal viel Spaß dabei. Jetzt aber Schluss. Chaosradio Express macht hier ein Ende. Nummer 73 ist im Kasten. Und wie immer, ich bitte um Feedback Chaosradio at cccde per E-Mail oder im Blog blog.chaosradio.cccde dort was posten. Gerne auch hilfreiche Links, Kommentare zur Sendung, was war gut, was war schlecht, ist alles immer ganz gerne gehört. Das ist ein Feedback liebendes Projekt hier Chaosradio Express. Gut, das war's. Danke, Denis. Und wir sagen Tschüss, bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.